there have been more than 30 harry
potter video game titles across pc
handhelds home consoles and mobile
devices there have been major
partnerships with key companies like
lego experimental titles using the xbox
kinect and playstation move and of
course they are the main line titles
that coincided with each new movie
release people of the internet
retrorecontour here i'm just a dad who
loves games and the stories they tell
and this is the complete history of the
harry potter video games
the choices you make now
will define the legacy
of hogwarts
many think of harry potter and the
philosopher's stone as being the first
hp video game however that title
actually belongs to lego creator harry
potter
the game was developed for pc by
superscape and published by lego
software in 2001. being a lego game it's
no surprise it focused heavily on
building and player creation it
contained four different worlds
including diagon alley king's cross
station the hogwarts grounds and
hogwarts itself the characters were
modeled after lego's harry potter sets
at the time which have certainly seen
some changes over the years as far as
how the game actually played the
animation was stiff and a bit wonky at
times but it's easy to see how kids who
love lego and harry potter would be
intrigued by the game when it comes to
the actual release date information
available online today is surprisingly
inconclusive i found dates ranging from
march 21st to october 26 2001. all of
them do seem to agree however that it
was not only the first harry potter
video game released but also the first
licensed lego video game ever released
as well now there had been lego games
before but this marked the first time
lego worked with a third-party franchise
seeing just how much lego's video game
business has grown today makes it quite
a fascinating footnote to history that
it all started with harry potter super i
think malfoy is beginning to regret his
naughtiness now just once more 2001 was
a huge turning point for the harry
potter franchise as the first film was
released to the world along with a video
game
[Music]
the video game launched on the pc sony
playstation game boy color and game boy
advance in november of 2001.
philosopher's stone is the game many
fans think of when remembering the
origins of the harry potter series in
video games one of the most interesting
notes about the first game is just how
different the versions were the pc game
was developed by no wonder while
argonaut games handled the playstation
version aside from technical aspects
such as resolution and frame rate modern
gamers would probably find it bizarre
for a single title to play so
differently across platforms but not
only did these titles play differently
they were built completely differently
as well the pc version put players in
control of harry after his arrival at
hogwarts the game used a third person
perspective and had players learning new
spells by attending classes and solving
simple puzzles throughout the castle
despite hogwarts being somewhat open for
exploration the missions were fairly
straightforward and linear spells in the
game included flopindo the video game
version of the knockback jinx along with
alohomora wingardium leviosa lumos and
incendio the spells were contextual and
while they could be cast at any time by
the player they would only react to
specific objects in the game most of the
spells behaved as you would expect with
the exception of lumos which revealed
hidden platforms rather than acting as a
charm to lighter wizard's wand like we
see in the books and movies the
playstation version was also third
person but the story did not follow the
same order as the pc version there were
also different gameplay elements and
scenes that weren't featured in the pc
game sure there were plenty of
similarities including the fact that
both games managed to include quidditch
and wizard cards as collectibles as for
the handheld versions even though the
game boy color and game boy advance
games were both developed by kryptonite
games they too played rather differently
the game boy color title was an rpg and
seemingly inspired by games like pokemon
and final fantasy the gba version was a
top-down puzzle game instead overall the
games received fairly middling review
scores although there was a clear nod to
the game boy color version being the
best at least in the eyes of video game
journalists given the popularity of the
series as a whole though it's no
surprise the game sold well philosopher
stone was the top selling pc game in the
month of december 2001 in february of
2002 the npd group listed it as the
third highest selling pc game of the
previous year with more than 800 000
copies sold this was despite the fact
that it didn't release until november
the game would go on to sell well above
1 million copies for pc the playstation
version was even better with absolutely
massive sales numbers of more than 8
million copies sold which actually make
it the sixth best-selling playstation
title of all time i was unable to find
sales numbers for the game boy color
version but the gba version did quite
well selling just shy of 700 000 copies
by august of 2006. harry potter and the
chamber of secrets released in november
of 2002 once again alongside the film
and once again with multiple versions no
wonder was back for the pc version
although this time they would also
release for mac as well argonaut games
tackled the ps1 version ea uk worked on
the ps2 gamecube and xbox versions
eurocom developed a version for game boy
advance which left kryptonite with just
the game boy color version this go-round
that's right five different versions of
the game and honestly even the gamecube
xbox and ps2 versions had a few
differences between them as well for
starters the gamecube version was the
only one to support a special feature
that allowed players to access a secret
room if they connected to the gameboy
advance version using a gamecube gba
link cable and despite more technical
power in the gamecube and xbox neither
of those versions permitted players to
roam freely across the grounds and to
land anywhere using the free flight mode
which was possible on the ps2 version
other than that these console versions
were very similar and featured a
hogwarts castle that provided a little
more freedom than the pc game wizard
cards also made a return as did bertie
bought every flavor beans here they also
introduced a lost items bulletin board
which was found in the gryffindor common
room these items were hidden in various
locations throughout the school and
along the hogwarts grounds for each item
found players were rewarded with a
famous witcher wizard card the pc
version was a direct sequel to no
wonders version of philosopher stone the
graphic style and character models were
mostly the same although there was a
definite improvement to the way the game
controlled on mouse and keyboard some
spells learned in the first game were
retained but players took classes to
learn new spells as well the puzzles and
overall flow of the game were also
improved compared to the first yet it
once again played out very differently
than the console versions argonaut's
version for playstation can be looked at
as a direct sequel to the philosopher's
stone version of the game that they made
for ps1 some areas of hogwarts were
expanded upon from the first game or
moved slightly although the models and
graphics were mostly the same they did
introduce some new minigames and other
slight gameplay improvements gryptonite
once again went with an rpg style for
the game boy color version while eurocom
made an adventure-style puzzle-driven
game for gba critics appeared marginally
more pleased with chamber of secrets
when compared to philosopher stone but
not by much most publications scored the
gamecube and xbox version slightly
higher than the ps2 version but this
wasn't true across the board it's also
important to keep in mind there weren't
nearly as many game reviews posted then
as there are today to put it into
perspective metacritic only has 8 scores
for the pc version and only 16 for the
ps2 version compare that to a recently
released modern third party title like
death loop for example and you'll see
that the ps5 version has more than 100
critical reviews at the time of this
recording sales for chamber of secrets
were incredibly strong yet again in fact
when all of the versions are combined
the news and observer reports more than
9 million copies were sold lego would
also release lego creator harry potter
in the chamber of secrets in 2002
although a sequel to the first lego
creator harry potter game this one
wasn't developed by superscape cube
software worked on the project and it
was published by ea and lego interactive
the sequel built upon the first game by
including more models worlds and
minifigures with no harry potter films
scheduled for release in 2003 that
presented a unique opportunity for wb
and ea that holiday season rather than
releasing a title based on a book for a
not yet released movie they instead
opted to release a spin-off game in the
form of harry potter quidditch world cup
[Music]
quidditch world cup was a deep dive into
a fan favorite pastime of the wizarding
world even though there weren't any new
movies that year the harry potter and
the goblet of fire book released just a
few years prior in the year 2000 of
course one of the standout scenes and
world building moments of this
installment in the series was harry
attending the quidditch world cup the
game started out simple enough with
players choosing one of the four
hogwarts house teams and learning
through a series of exhibition matches
challenges and ultimately playing in the
hogwarts quidditch cup against the other
house teams witch world cup did a
fantastic job with the small details
like including actual names of players
and students fans would recognize from
the books after winning the hogwarts cup
players unlocked the world cup and
that's where things really got
interesting england the united states
japan germany france australia the
nordic team spain and bulgaria were all
available although bulgaria had to be
unlocked and an interesting design
choice both the hogwarts cup and the
world cup are actually determined by
points and not wins this meant that the
team with the highest point total after
all games were played is actually the
team that would be crowned champion
which may not necessarily be the team
with the most wins even though the
gameplay was a radical departure from
previous harry potter video games
critical reception was mostly the same
with reviews averaging around 70
the pc gamecube xbox and ps2 versions
were developed by ea uk however there
was also a gba version developed by
magic pockets that unsurprisingly played
quite a bit differently this version
didn't review nearly as well though as
the full-fledged console versions with
the incredible sales numbers of the
original release of philosopher stone
it's no surprise wb attempted to
capitalize on the success for a new
generation of systems in december 2003
developer warthog games would release
yet another version of philosopher stone
but this time for sony's playstation 2
nintendo's gamecube and microsoft's xbox
this version reused many of the assets
from 2002's console version of harry
potter and the chamber of secrets and
the gameplay is similar yet again though
it proved to be quite a different
experience from the pc and ps1 versions
that came before this remake had a story
that followed the film much more closely
but reviewed slightly lower than the
philosopher's stone versions that
preceded it in the summer of 2004 it was
back to a traditional release with harry
potter and the prisoner of azkaban
hitting theaters and yet another movie
tie-in game to release alongside it no
wonder made the pc version kryptonite
the game boy advance version and ea uk
for the gamecube ps2 and xbox versions
all versions were natural progressions
based on the games that came before
however they all had a fairly big shift
by featuring the trio of harry ron and
hermione more prominently than in
previous games in fact all three were
playable characters for the first time
and the console versions even let you
switch between the three at will for
most sections of the game there are
spells that are unique to certain
members of the trio which come into play
when solving puzzles or trying to
progress through certain levels there
are also some bizarre design decisions
for the console version such as the fact
that harry is the only character who can
jump across chasms like the chamber of
secrets console game before it there
were also moments where players needed
to summon hedwig for assistance both
versions also have sequences where the
player can ride buckbeak the hippogriff
the pc version remained more focused on
puzzles whereas the console versions
continue to be more of a third person
action-adventure game with puzzle
elements sprinkled throughout bertie
bought beans returned and were once
again used to buy items from fred and
george wizard cards chocolate frogs
cauldron cakes dung bombs and several
other items returned from previous games
as well as for the gba version it was
once again a traditional role-playing
game it did differ from the gba games
before it by opting for turn-based
combat rather than the real-time combat
of the previous gba games although the
game boy color games before it did
feature turn-based battles critical
reviews of both versions once again
hovered in that 70 range with the ps2
version scoring the best the pc version
came in at 67
despite the completely different
gameplay the gba version was also met
with middling review scores in the 70
range commercially the games were
another huge success even selling 316
000 copies in the launch month alone
2004 would also see the release of the
first ever harry potter mobile game
which was titled harry potter find
scabbers the gameplay was rather simple
as players would search for scabbers as
he makes his way through an assortment
of different mazes unfortunately this
game was not well received ign's review
of the game said quote harry potter
finds scabbers isn't much fun to begin
with but when you consider the richness
of the source material the game becomes
disheartening and disappointing close
quote despite the poor first attempt it
certainly wouldn't be the last harry
potter mobile game harry potter and the
goblet of fire released in 2005 and saw
quite a few changes compared to the
previous core games in the series for
starters no wonder was no longer in the
picture and did not develop a pc version
instead the pc version was developed by
ea uk and it was largely the same as the
ps2 gamecube and xbox versions the
team-based mechanic of prisoner of
azkaban was carried over here and
expanded upon the graphics started to
shift even more to make the characters
look like their movie counterparts
perhaps the most disappointing change
with goblet of fire is how it completely
did away with the more free roaming
gameplay found in the first three games
instead it was more action focused and
broken up into different levels as
players competed in the triwizard
tournament in addition to a handful of
other scenes found in the books and
movies and possibly as a result of these
changes players no longer controlled the
game's camera in fact the pc version was
controlled entirely by the keyboard with
no mouse input at all on the more
positive side goblet of fire brought
multiplayer co-op support to the series
for the first time this meant you could
have friends take on the role of ron and
hermione together the trio could combine
spells for more power when playing alone
most levels gave players the option to
pick one of the three main characters
with the exception being levels that
involved one of the triwizard tasks
magic pockets developed the game for the
game boy advance and nintendo ds while
ea fusion uk handled the psp version the
gba and ds versions were fairly similar
but neither were an rpg as had been the
custom for at least one of the handheld
versions in the past the psp version was
also its own thing however it tried to
be closer to the home console versions
than its nintendo handheld counterparts
even with these changes critical
reception for a goblet of fire was
mostly the same as previous games in the
mainline series hovering around an
average of 68 to 70 percent most
longtime fans of the series agree though
that goblet of fire was a clear drop off
from the first games that came before it
harry potter and the order of the
phoenix restored the open world
exploration from the original three
games and made some of the best attempts
to please fans of the series even going
as far to involve a fan council to
assist during the development process as
part of the game's open world nature
players could earn discovery points as
they made their way through hogwarts and
use spells to interact with objects
environmental spells included accio
dipulso wingardium leviosa incendio
rapero and reducto wizard duels also
made a return with the finale even
putting players in the shoes of albus
dumbledore for his epic duel against
lord voldemort and the department of
mysteries for much of the game however
players only control harry which was a
departure from the previous two entries
that had emphasized teamwork of the main
trio and speaking of dumbledore
dumbledore's army is also featured
prominently throughout the game combat
spells include stupefy expelliarmus
protego rictum simpra levocorpus
petrovicus totalis and expecto patronum
author jk rowling also played a more
prominent role in the development even
suggesting different characters for
certain missions based on their
personality within the wizarding world
she also helped with rules for the
various wizarding world mini-games that
appeared like gobstones and exploding
snap with the advancements in video game
technology they were even able to scan
faces of certain characters from the
movie cast like rupert grint and ivana
lynch the layout and appearance of
hogwarts was also based on the movie
version of the castle ea uk developed
the game for pc mac ps2 ps3 xbox and the
nintendo wii which proved to be the most
popular version thanks in large part to
the wii remote wand controls it also
didn't hurt that the nintendo wii was an
insanely big seller while the overall
feel and lore of the game proved to be
close to the source material maybe more
so than any harry potter game before it
the gameplay itself left much to be
desired the pc ps3 and 360 versions
certainly had the best graphics but the
wii version was the most well received
among critics despite the improvements
in fan involvement however many
reviewers felt the gameplay was too easy
and repetitive which resulted in most
scores falling below 70 percent pretty
much across all platforms the ds and gba
versions which were developed by visual
impact scored poorly as well as did the
psp version which was developed by
rebellion developments and for the first
time in the series a mobile version was
released by ea mobile somewhat
surprisingly these java games actually
looked incredible for their time with
particularly strong lighting effects
they also featured wizard tools flights
with hedwig and plenty of stealth
sequences throughout hogwarts all things
considered many felt this to be an
incredibly solid attempt at making a
mobile game worthy of the harry potter
name and that wasn't the only mobile
harry potter game released in 2007 ea
mobile also released harry potter
mastering magic for mobile phones mobile
games were certainly still in their
infancy in 2007 which is probably why
mastering magic was simply a collection
of mini games eight to be exact that
being said the games themselves weren't
half bad and featured classes from the
wizarding world such as divination care
of magical creatures and herbology
unfortunately the game suffered from the
same as many games in the series by
being too repetitive and too easy once
the lessons were completed players would
take their ordinary wizarding level exam
which did help to boost the challenge
somewhat harry potter and the half blood
prince released in 2009 and fans were
hopeful the series would continue moving
in a positive direction after the
changes that were made for order of the
phoenix free roaming hogwarts quidditch
and wizard duels all made a return
however many found the gameplay
repetitive yet again you would primarily
control harry although there are
segments featuring ron and jenny as
playable characters as well many of the
spells from the previous game returned
but no new ones were added the wii
version utilized the wii remote once
again for spell casting and also added
we remote functionality to brewing
potions given the storyline of half
blood prince it only made sense for
potions to be featured more prominently
and that's certainly the case across all
versions of the game there are numerous
potion brewing segments including one
with felix felicis the production value
continued to increase as characters
looked more like their movie
counterparts than ever before thanks to
advancements of console hardware at the
time many of the movie voice actors also
returned including rupert grint as ron
bonnie wright as jenny tom felton as
draco and plenty of others unfortunately
the animations were rough and at times
bad enough to actually pull you out of
the experience and unfortunately the
entire game could be completed in
roughly three and a half hours overall
half blood prince didn't innovate enough
to see much critical success as most
reviewers scored it slightly lower than
its predecessors the nintendo ds version
used stylus controls and wasn't nearly
as well received by reviewers earning a
4.4 out of 10 from ign the psp version
was scored similar to the ds version the
mobile game once again proved to be a
pleasant surprise like order of the
phoenix before it the visual
presentation was top notch with detailed
character sprites and high quality
animation most of the gameplay involved
basic fetch quests where characters
needed help finding items within
hogwarts then players were tasked with
moving those items from one place to
another wizard duels helped to break up
the fetch quests but while potions and
quidditch were featured so prominently
in the console version they don't appear
at all in the mobile version harry
potter spells was another attempt at
capitalizing on the rapidly growing
mobile games market and this one was all
about transforming your ios device into
a wand after choosing a wand and getting
sorted which was actually random
surprisingly you would start to learn
the game's 14 different spells spells
were cast through a series of different
hand gestures once all 14 were mastered
players could move on to wizard duels
either against a computer-controlled
player or a friend with another ios
device and a copy of the game in 2010
it's hard to believe that nearly a
decade had passed since the chamber of
secrets lego creator game but wb and
lego partnered up once again for lego
harry potter years one through four and
this proved to be one of the standout
games of the series and still beloved by
fans today the lego formula for video
games was already well established by
2010 and that formula lent itself
perfectly to the harry potter franchise
the games focus on collecting exploring
solving puzzles and overall sense of
humor proved to be a huge hit with fans
spell casting was also made very simple
through the use of a spell wheel given
that the game covers the first four
years of harry's time at hogwarts it's
no surprise that it's packed with
content and unlockables which include
167 characters this certainly helped
lego harry potter to avoid the two short
complaints that had been made about
previous games in the series locations
included hogsmeade diagon alley and of
course hogwarts while the game does
feature a number of different levels it
also keeps things open for exploration
through free play the entirety of the
game can be played alongside a friend
thanks to the game's split screen mode
this alters the story somewhat as every
mission is playable with a friend the
game also featured very clever uses
apologies potion and even dark magic
which was required for solving some of
the puzzles lego creator harry potter
years 1 through 4 appeared on a
staggering number of platforms including
android ios nintendo ds and psp which
were developed by tt fusion travelers
tails made the primary version of the
game for pc mac nintendo wii ps3 and the
xbox 360. double 11 would later port the
game to ps4 xbox one and the nintendo
switch the console version was
overwhelmingly one of the best reviewed
harry potter games of the entire
franchise with a metacritic score of 80.
deathly hallows part 1 also released in
2010 and it too was a standout game in
the series but for all the wrong reasons
it did release alongside the movie and
in an effort to appeal to its aging core
audience ea completely altered the style
of its flagship harry potter movie
tie-in game deathly hallows part 1
changed the harry potter formula from an
action adventure with a focus on
exploration and puzzle solving into a
third person shooter the game heavily
relied on a cover system clearly
inspired by the likes of shooter titles
like cures of war the game even
emphasized landing headshots and
upgrading to stronger spells there was
no free roaming no quidditch and sadly
no hogwarts although the latter is a
result of the book and movie storyline
which took the trio out of their usual
setting as the fight against voldemort
entered its final chapter instead
players fight numerous death eaters
snatchers giant spiders dragons doxies
whomping willows and dementors somewhat
hilariously the game uses the elixir of
life as a healing item which fans know
was actually the potion nicholas flamel
created with the sorcerer's stone to
extend his life the decision to go more
action-oriented with deathly hallows was
certainly understandable however its
execution failed due to a messy
narrative style and the imprecise
gameplay mechanics side missions often
served no purpose other than to extend
the gameplay length and they completely
broke up the storyline that players
actually wanted to know about there were
stealth sections along the way which
tried to break up the action but
unfortunately both fans and critics
alike are nearly unanimous in their
disdain for deathly hallows part 1 and
part 2 for that matter the review scores
across the board were the lowest of the
series with a metacritic score of 37 out
of 100 for the pc version the nintendo
ds version was once again completely
different and focused primarily on
puzzle game play as a result it did see
slightly more favorable review scores
the mobile version of the game proved to
be another quality title once again
complete with outstanding visuals and a
strategic combat system pocketgamer gave
it a silver award and noted quote the
brilliant atmosphere challenging combat
and superb storytelling are a magical
recipe that any potions master would be
proud of close quote and although it
wasn't a traditional video game per se
screenlife games also published a mobile
version of the popular scenic game for
ios in 2010. the game featured hd clips
from the first six movies and included a
number of mini games to test players
memory in 2011 ea released what should
have been an epic conclusion to the
series that built upon all the titles
that came before to their credit ea did
hear the complaints on part one and
certainly attempted to remedy that with
part two but unfortunately the result
was another disappointing entry in the
harry potter series on the positive side
ea attempted to tell the story in a
linear fashion that followed the movie
more closely than part one by not
including those seemingly random
unnecessary side missions and went back
to a spell casting system that mapped
spells to the face buttons they also
added sequences with more playable
characters in an attempt to capture the
collective efforts of wizards fighting
on harry's side throughout the series
and in the battle of hogwarts playable
characters included harry ron hermione
ginny neville and even sheamus professor
mcgonagall and molly weasley
unfortunately the overall gameplay and
progression once again suffered with
boring level designs and wave after wave
of death eaters to fight the game also
proved to be another short experience
that could be beaten in around 3 hours
all in all it was a disappointing
conclusion even by the mediocre
standards of the movie tie-in games that
came before it this time around even the
mobile version was somewhat of a
disappointment gameloft handled
development rather than ea mobile and
the game suffered as a result of this
change the graphics and animations were
praised yet again but the gameplay fell
flat pocketgamer said quote but when it
comes to play itself and the beguiling
plot that rests heavy upon it harry
potter and the deathly hallows part 2 is
neither engaging enough to mop up those
with a casual interest or active enough
to serve those first in the queue at the
flicks close quote fortunately for harry
potter fans deathly hallows part 2
wasn't the only potter video game to
release in 2011. traveler's tales was
back with the sequel to its first lego
harry potter game lego harry potter
years five through seven covered the
events from order of the phoenix all the
way to the series conclusion in deathly
hallows the game once again delivered
the classic lego formula with two-player
co-op humor fun yet simple mechanics and
a plethora of extras to unlock although
some scenes are changed from the books
and movies often for comedic effect the
lego games did a great job at including
the most iconic moments throughout
harry's final years at hogwarts
including the battle at the department
of mysteries dumbledore and harry's
fight against and fury in the cave and
of course harry's final confrontation
with voldemort himself like years one
through four lego harry potter years
five through seven remains one of the
best-reviewed potter games to date with
aggregate scores in the high 70s to low
80s depending on the platform the ds and
psp versions were both scaled back
versions of the console games as a
result they didn't review as well but
most still found them to be enjoyable
following the release of deathly hallows
part 2 and lego harry potter years 5
through 7 in 2011 the franchise entered
a new era for the series as no other
books or movies were on the horizon in
2012 wb released what can best be
described as experimental titles heavy
on gimmicks with harry potter for the
microsoft connect wonder book book of
spells for the playstation 3 and then
wonder book book of potions also for ps3
harry potter connect was an exclusive
title for the xbox 360 and
unsurprisingly required the kinect
accessory spells were performed with
physical gestures and verbal
incantations this game was clearly
geared toward a younger audience
considering its actively tiring controls
and short overall length book of spells
seemed to fare a little bit better with
critics the title actually came about as
a result of a partnership between jk
rowling's pottermore website and sony
computer entertainment the game was
developed by sony's london studio and
even gave users the option to link the
game to their pottermore accounts which
would then in turn match the player's
wand and hogwarts house from their
pottermore account as far as the actual
gameplay book of spells was an augmented
reality experience that was exclusive to
playstation and took advantage of the
itoy and playstation move accessories
like the wii remote before it move
controller was a natural fit to simulate
one motions through augmented reality
with the itoy the move controller itself
appears as a wand on the tv screen the
title book of spells is actually
inspired by the textbook written by
miranda goshawk in the series in what is
seemingly a common theme for many of the
harry potter games the overall
experience ended up being rather short
and not worth the price of a
full-fledged release critics did praise
the actual mechanics of the game and its
clever use of the playstation move
controller wonder book book of potions
released in 2013 as a follow-up and
featured nearly identical gameplay but
with more of a focus on brewing potions
rather than casting spells
jk rowling created a completely new
character zigment budge who guided
players in their potion making
throughout the game
i am sigmund budge
i discovered the properties of hundreds
of secret plants and creatures
budge attended hogwarts at some point
between the years of 1501 and 1594 but
his house is unknown in the forward of
book of potions budge claims to have
invented many of the wizarding world's
most powerful potions as far as critical
reception book of potions went by
largely unnoticed to reviewers it
actually only received one critical
review score on metacritic the daily
telegraph's andy robertson published one
of the few reviews for the game and gave
it an overall positive review after book
of potions in 2013 the series went quiet
for a long stretch even though there
weren't any new books or movies it's
somewhat surprising to see that the
series lay dormant for so long in 2016
though that changed as wb released a
brand new film set in the wizarding
world fantastic beasts and where to find
them a prequel to the events of harry
potter somewhat surprisingly wb did not
create a major video game for the
release of fantastic beasts they did
however release a new mobile game for
android and ios fantastic beasts cases
from the wizarding world
wb games san francisco partnered with
developer mediatonic to create a
single-player hidden object style game
where players controlled a member of the
beast division in the department for
regulation and control of magical
creatures the game took players to
familiar locations such as hogsmeade the
leaky cauldron and diagon alley there
were 14 different cases for players to
solve which always involved uncovering a
hidden magical beast causing some sort
of unexplained happenings around it
players would find hidden objects cast
spells brew potions and identify beasts
to crack the case unfortunately the game
was officially shut down in january of
2020. from 2018 through 2021 wb only
released a handful of mobile titles for
the harry potter franchise including
harry potter hogwarts mystery in 2018
harry potter wizards unite in 2019 harry
potter puzzles and spells in 2020 and
harry potter magic awakened in 2021
hogwarts mystery is a single-player
narrative-based role-playing game
developed by jam city under licensing
from portkey games it takes place after
harry potter's birth but before his
enrollment at hogwarts with this
timeline many characters fans know from
the series such as dumbledore mcgonagall
and snape make an appearance here
players will also meet and work
alongside bill weasley who's a student
at hogwarts at the same time as the
player all of the elements you'd expect
are here such as learning spells brewing
potions and playing quidditch the game
even covers a full seven years at
hogwarts and the choices you make along
the way impact certain story elements
and your relationship with other
characters unfortunately while the game
is free it's riddled with micro
transactions and incredibly frustrating
pay to win mechanics in fact the prices
were so egregious that fan backlash led
to a price cut on many of these
microtransactions both reviewers and
fans alike have criticized the pay
structure of the game and many
specifically noted an early scene that
immediately depletes your energy meter
and then requires you to either wait
half an hour for the energy to replenish
or pay real world money to instantly
refill the energy meter even with these
criticisms the game grossed 55 million
in revenue by august 2018 and more than
100 million by march of 2019. at the
time of this recording hogwarts mystery
is still being supported with new
updates harry potter wizards unite is a
mobile title developed and published by
niantic under licensing from portkey
games and yes it's the very same niantic
who created the incredibly popular
pokemon go like pokemon go the gameplay
is based around augmented reality and
location-based gameplay players needed
to physically visit real world locations
and use their mobile device to cast
spells discover artifacts and meet up
with familiar characters and fantastic
beasts from the wizarding world of harry
potter similar to most potter games
before it you'll choose your wand and
house at the start of the game but in
this one you'll also need to pick a
profession you can be a professor auror
or magic zoologist by may of 2021 the
title had been downloaded 20 million
times and had a total revenue of 37
million unfortunately the game fell
short of expectations and in november of
2021 they announced plans to remove the
game from all app stores in december and
then fully shut down the game in january
of 2022. harry potter puzzles and spells
is yet another harry potter mobile game
although this one was developed by the
mobile gaming giant zynga and published
by port g games in september of 2020 it
was released on android ios kindle and
facebook
at its core puzzles and spells is a
match 3 puzzle game that includes
familiar wizarding world locations like
diagon alley and hogwarts among others
it puts a spin on the classic match 3
formula by having various harry potter
spells and items that you can earn along
the way to help you clear the puzzles
the game is free to play but does
feature some microtransactions at the
time of this video recording it has more
than 134 000 ratings on ios with an
impressive 4.8 out of 5 average score
it's also still being actively supported
by zynga with frequent updates and a
story that spans across multiple books
harry potter magic awakened is a
wizarding world mobile game that just
recently had its official launch but
only in select territories it's an rpg
card game for pc android and ios and
it's set 10 years after harry potter's
victory over voldemort in the battle of
hogwarts it was first announced back in
october of 2019 and is being developed
by netease and published by wb under the
portkey games label with this game
taking place so close to the original
series there are actually quite a few
familiar faces that players will
interact with throughout the game the
main character's journey starts similar
to harry's when the half rubius hagrid
shows up to deliver a letter of
acceptance to a young muggleborn hagrid
teaches them about the wizarding world
and joins them on their first trip to
diagon alley the story really kicks off
at the sorting ceremony when a fellow
first-year ivy warrington goes missing
players will get to choose their
hogwarts house attend classes explore
the castle and even join the dueling
club most of the action and spell
casting will be centered on the game's
card based combat system the game has
impressed so far but a large portion of
the harry potter fan base is still
awaiting its release in more territories
and so that brings us to the modern day
with one harry potter game looming on
the horizon and set to release in 2022.
that's right it's hogwarts legacy that
common bond we share
is the legacy of hogwarts
with the incredible success of the
franchise over the years it shouldn't
come as a shock to anyone that even more
harry potter games are in development to
this day at the time of this video
recording hogwarts legacy is in
development at avalanche software with
plans to publish under the portkey games
label players will create their own
witch or wizard and step into a late
1800s wizarding world long before harry
defeats voldemort at the battle of
hogwarts the game is an open world
action rpg and given the incredible
success of the genre in recent years
fans are hopeful this could finally be
the harry potter game to buck the trend
of being merely acceptable and hopefully
moving up to exceeding expectations or
possibly even outstanding even with the
late 1800s timing players will travel to
familiar locations such as the forbidden
forest and hogsmeade village magical
creatures will feature prominently and a
number of them have already been
confirmed including centaurs goblins
grab horns moon calves spiders trolls
and hippogriffs despite the lengthy
history of video games set in the
wizarding world long time fans of the
series are still holding out hope for a
game that can fully capture the magic of
the rich and vibrant world fans fell in
love with so many years ago today many
players look back on the video game
titles fondly while i can't speak for
everyone at least for me there's
certainly the question of what might
have been what might have been without
rush development cycles to hit a movie
release date what might have been had
developers been able to maintain more
consistency especially later in the
series it's safe to say that harry
potter video games are here to stay but
it remains to be seen if any will be
able to fully capture the sense of
wonder exploration and magic that so
many fans feel is possible for video
games set in the wizarding world even
with all the what-ifs the feeling of
nostalgia is strong with many titles
from the series and i certainly have
fond memories from them myself in fact
i've actually been playing through many
of the old harry potter games here on my
channel you can check out my let's plays
on the right side of your screen or if
you're looking for more information
about future harry potter games like
hogwarts legacy then check out the video
on the left side of your screen thank
you for coming along this journey with
me as always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon